[Musique]
c'est sur la place de l'église des Trois
Bassins ce mercredi 8 juin que la
caravane d'accès aux droits et à
l'information a fait son premier arrêt
rapprocher les services départementaux
des publics vulnérables et isolés c'est
ce que propose ce nouveau point
d'accueil mobile inauguré en ce jour par
les élus du département ainsi que ses
partenaires
de descendre vers les sous-préfecture et
bien la caravane d'accès aux droits
c'était un plus que le Conseil général à
aménagé qui va aller dans les quartiers
ou à expliquer aux familles les droits
des apprenants que ce soit pour les
enfants pour les personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées et bien il existe
des aides la caravane du droit c'était
un moyen de que nos services aillent
vers la population de façon à ce que
vous ayez même si j'habite dans les
Hauts je t'habitent loin les mêmes
droits que les habitants qui habitent au
centre-ville de tous les centres villes
de La Réunion et c'est avec beaucoup de
joie et d'enthousiasme que nous durant
cette caravane d'accès au droit qui est
financée dans le cadre du Plan pauvreté
pour justement aller vers aller dans les
zones où il y a pas forcément accès au
service sociaux et de mettre en place
les démarches nécessaires pour les
accompagner à défendre leurs droits
inscrite à la stratégie nationale de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté la caravane départementale a
pour but d'offrir des conditions
d'accueil équitables aux quatre coins du
territoire pour tenter de répondre au
mieux aux besoins du public le
département a misé sur une équipe
pluridisciplinaire l'idée c'est qu'on
est à minima les services de polyvalence
insertion qui soit présent avec
travailleur sociaux agents
administratifs les services de PMI et
également les intervenants sociaux en
commissariat et gendarmerie l'idée c'est
qu'on soit sur un socle commun
d'accès aux droits et d'informations et
de prévention d'accompagnement à la
parentalité et en fonction de
l'analyse et des
[Musique]